[Music]
the way I have instilled like for human
children with the human values that I
prefer is mostly not by preaching at
them what's right and what's wrong
that's not very effective especially for
people with the contrarian personality
which somehow all my kids ended up with
I don't know how the the way I inculcate
them with some approximation of the
values that are important to me is just
my you know spending time with them in
various situations and if your children
enter into various situations with you
and see how you respond to various
things and how you guide them to respond
to various things in real life then your
kids pick up sort of by osmosis right I
mean I mean they pick up due to the
their desire to imitate and to learn
them to follow that they pick up the
practicalities of your values and and
and your culture and interestingly this
can stick with him on an implicit level
even if on a surface level many values
change right so I mean of one of my
son's became a Sufi Muslim at one point
and you know some of his values are on
the surface very different different
than mine now I mean I'm not Muslim I'm
not religious in any conventional sense
on the other hand you know he's he's
very compassionate Khan tarded person
he's very intellectual he's a scholar so
if you look in a practical level the
vast bulk of the values and culture he
got from myself and his mom when he was
growing up you know it's implicit rather
than a list of rules but it but it's
it's all still there right now for an AI
I think we need to take an approach
somewhat similar to what we do with with
human children we need to have a eyes
working and playing side by side with us
in real situations we need to give the
eyes you know a desire to
imitate us on a basic level and to
understand you know why we're reacting
how we react in this after this after
this concrete situation and then the AI
can get a practical model of our values
in our culture as its manifested you
know in a hundred thousand or a million
real-life situations and this this
doesn't guarantee the AI will always
respond the way we want but it will give
it a real foundation which you're not
going to get from giving a list of like
the three or ten laws of being a good
human or a good human like mind an
important thing to remember when you
talk about getting human values into an
AI is that human values are very much a
moving target all right I mean much of
what we do in our everyday lives would
have been considered horrendously
immoral by the average human of the
Middle Ages in Europe right or even for
that matter a lot of the things we take
for granted as being Moreland right now
we're concerned horrendously immoral by
almost everyone I went to elementary
school with in the 1970s in suburban New
Jersey right I mean look like my my mom
is is gay and because of that in the
1970s because our car turned over got
all the windows of our house smashed and
like that was completely unacceptable in
the 1970s in southern New Jersey now I
mean gay marriage is being legalized
everywhere right so I mean it's human
values even in our lifetime have changed
a lot so when you get to a technological
singularity with brain computer
interfacing and mind uploading and
superhuman a eyes and we're able to you
know clone our body over and over again
our values are not going to remain
precisely the same as they are now even
for us humans so it it's absurd to think
we could start an AI with our current
human values and they're going to stick
with our
18 human values forever our own values
are going to drift right so all we can
ask for is the AI starts out with the
values that we hold dear now and as its
values grow and evolve this growth and
evolution is coupled with our own growth
and evolution whose direction we cannot
foresee at this time
[Music]